[Musique]
bonjour je me présente je m'appelle
romain cazalis j'ai 46 ans et comme
obélix je suis tombé dedans quand
j'étais petit pas dans la potion magique
bien évidemment dans l'électronique
à 12 ans je commence à bidouiller mes
premiers montages à 16 ans j'assemble
mon premier ordinateur que je me suis
acheté en pièces détachées à 19 ans j'ai
intégré une école d'ingénieurs en 24 ans
j'en fais mon métier ça fait donc
maintenant un peu plus de 20 ans en 2011
j'embarque aborde une start up qui
démarre cinq ans plus tard nous sommes
150 avons développés dits produits que
nous vendons dans le monde entier
voilà pour les présentations si je suis
devant vous ce soir c'est pour vous
parler de renaissance de renaissance
technologique bien évidemment celle des
objets connectés
c'est quoi un objet connecté
prenez n'importe quel objet qui existe
déjà
ajoutez-y une connexion à internet sans
fil de préférence et vous avez un objet
connecté
c'est simple non le premier objet dont
certainement tout le monde a entendu
parler ici c'est le frigo moi je
voudrais rajouter des drones les
balances des caméras des montres des
appareils photos des voitures
la liste est infinie le premier exemple
dont je voudrais vous parler ce soir est
un produit sorti en 2012 la station
météo station météo il s'en fabrique des
millions chaque année
elles permettent de mesurer la
température l'humidité la pression
atmosphérique à l'intérieur comme à
l'extérieur de chez soi toutes ces
valeurs sont affichées sur un grand
écran à cristaux liquides très bien
maintenant supprimer l'écran un peu
moche
ajoutez-y une puce wifi et vous obtenez
une station météo connectez vous
disposez maintenant des mêmes mesures
mais sur un bel écran couleur celui que
vous avez toujours dans la poche
le smartphone pour compléter ces mesures
cette station dispose d'un sonomètre
pour mesurer le bruit ambiant et d'un
capteur de co2 grâce à ces indicateurs
de qualité d'air elle me permet
d'améliorer mon confort au quotidien
prenez le co2 c'est un merveilleux
indicateurs de confinement si une ou
plusieurs personnes sont dans une même
pièce
le taux de co2 grimpe le co2 n'a pas
d'odeur et n'est pas toxique en même
temps à forte dose fatigue et à très
fortes doses il demain à était cette
station vous prévient donc quand le taux
de co2 est trop élevé elle s'allume en
rouge et vous envoie une notification
dans votre téléphone pour vous
recommander d'ouvrir la fenêtre
ces smart non
comme deuxième exemple je vais parler
d'un produit plus récent le thermostat
celui de ma chaudière jeu les remplacer
par un thermostat connectés cela me
permet de piloter de contrôler ma
chaudière à distance depuis un
ordinateur ou mon téléphone
les avantages sont nombreux d'abord je
maximise mes économies d'énergie car les
possibilités de réglages sont quasi
infinies bien supérieure à celle de mon
ancien thermostat avant pour régler le
programme hebdomadaire
je devais faire défiler deux meilleurs
par demi heure les sept jours de la
semaine
si j'avais le malheur de me tromper il
fallait tout recommencer depuis le début
un vrai cauchemar
plus de 300 clique de boutons avec la
version connais tu es tout est simple
facile à utiliser et à régler tout se
fait en quelques secondes sur le
téléphone de plus comme il sait où
j'habite il est capable d'aller chercher
sur des sites météo sur internet
la température qu'il fait à l'extérieur
de chez moi il s'en sert pour anticiper
le temps qu'il faudra à la chaudière
pour passer de 17 à 20 degrés au petit
matin
s'il fait moins cinq d'or il démarre à
la chaudière plutôt que s'il fait plus
10 bien évidemment quand je pars en
vacances je peux couper le chauffage
je peux le rallumer quelques heures
avant de revenir un jour j'ai laissé ma
fille de 15 ans à la maison elle était
grippé et ne pouvaient pas aller aller
au lycée tout à coup j'ai réalisé que le
chauffage aller ce coupé puisque
normalement en semaine il ya personne à
la maison c'est vraiment idiot de
laisser une personne grippée dans une
maison froide et bien pas de problème
depuis mon bureau j'ai remis la consigne
a que 20 degrés pour toute la journée
comme dernier exemple je vais parler de
produits que nous utilisons tous ici
plusieurs fois par jour les instructeurs
et les prises
alors malheureusement ils sont pas
encore disponibles mais ils le seront
dans moins d'un an
ces appareils ces nouveaux appareils
ressembleront exactement au modèle que
nous connaissons actuellement il se
brancheront avec deux fils et ils seront
interconnectés internet
brace utiliseront de la même façon si
j'appuie sur le bouton
évidemment la lumière s'allume mais en
plus je pourrais aller commander à
distance la prise il sera capable de
mesurer la consommation de l'appareil
qui est branché dessus c'est idéal pour
surveiller son frigidaire ou son
congélateur elle sera en mesure de vous
avertir quand celui ci tombe en panne ou
en cas de panne de courant pour les
interrupteurs vous n'avez jamais eu
envie d'en déplacer 1 ou de rajouter un
dans une pièce et bien ce sera facile la
version à piles plus de fils vous
n'aurez plus à faire courir les files
sur les plaintes faire des saignées dans
les murs vous les placerait où vous
voulez et même sur un meuble
si ça vous chante il et repositionnable
vous voulez déplacer le lit vers la
droite
problème vous le prenez il va suivre le
lit on pourra modifier son installation
électrique sans l'intervention d'un
électricien et pour finir il existera
des télécommandes spéciale qui
permettront de jouer des scénarios
préprogrammés par exemple le dernier
couché dans la chambre des parents qui
permet d'éteindre toutes les lumières le
dernier parti à la porte d'entrée qui en
plus ferme les volets ou bien la
simulation de présence qui allumera est
un bras de manière aléatoire
toutes les pièces dans votre maison
quand vous êtes absent bref voilà pour
les intérêts les avantages des objets
connectés
mais si vous avez suivi c'est quoi au
juste
c'est la renaissance de la maison
intelligente et il y en aura partout
d'ici cinq ans il y en aura plusieurs
dizaines dans toutes les maisons
pourquoi pour trois raisons principales
la première la disponibilité de la
connexion internet internet sans fil est
partout faites l'exercice
sortez dans la rue un numéro de
téléphone comptez le nombre de réseaux
wifi pouvait capter ces fascinants j'ai
fait l'exercice
juste derrière la médiathèque jean capte
cette deuxième raison le prix voici un
chip wifi bon alors c'est vrai qu'en
préparant cette présentation je m'étais
dit que j'allais montrer des choses
était plus vivant je n'allais pas
utiliser le rétroprojecteur
voilà je peux pas m'en passer je pense
qu'au fond personne voit rien voici la
seule image que je souhaite vous montrer
le type wifi en grand en cinq ans
d'activité dans ce secteur
le prix de ces composants a été divisée
par 3 ça veut dire que d'ajouter la
fonction de connexion à internet coûtent
de moins en moins chères et donc la
différence de prix entre un appareil
classique et un appareil connecté var
complètement disparaître et pour la
troisième raison la facilité
d'utilisation les interfaces
utilisateurs sont de plus en plus
intuitive il faut au moins en moins
d'appuis son bouton pour atteindre telle
ou telle fonction
mais une vraie révolution est en train
d'arriver
l'intelligence artificielle elle fait
son apparition et elle va bouleverser
les usages des objets connectés
on va plus utiliser nos télécommande
pour contrôler nos appareils on va leur
parler on va dialoguer avec nos objets
connectés comme on le ferait avec
quelqu'un et d'ailleurs laissez moi vous
présenter alexa
elle est la création d'une société
américaine et n'est pas disponible
commercialement en france pourquoi parce
qu'aujourd'hui elle ne comprend que
l'anglais mais rassurez vous elle en
train d'apprendre le français et elle va
pas tarder à arriver
une petite démonstration alors on va lui
demander un calcul je sais que cette
pièce fait 15 mètres de large
19 mètres de long je veux lui demander
de calculer la superficie en anglais
bien évidemment alex a are much fft in
town norrington cette pièce fait donc de
185 mètres carrés vous partez en
australie vous voulez connaître le taux
de change
alexa arménie australienne dans le the
new year dollars 38 pour un euro et leur
local alex à houat times et lcd et voilà
ces appareils seront donc capables de
comprendre le langage naturel de
l'interpréter d'aller chercher
l'information sur internet et d'y
répondre
vous pourrez lui poser toutes les
questions qui vous passe par la tête
puis demander de jouer de la musique
une recette de cuisine l'orthographe
d'un mot et souvenez vous tout à l'heure
je vous ai parlé des interrupteurs
connectez vous pour aller commander
vocalement pourrais lui dire d'allumer
ou d'éteindre dans la cuisine ou en
salon de fermer les volets quand vous
partez tout sera beaucoup plus simple
plus besoin d'être un geek ou un
technophile
même ceux qui savent pas très bien
servir encore d'une tablette ou d'un
smartphone le langage ce sera très
simple c'est ça la renaissance de la
maison intelligente
[Applaudissements]
you can't sweat write off